les femmes que vous allez voir sur
toutes les patientes du plus grand
scientifique français de notre époque
zaur sarduy près de bien vouloir
m'excuser m le docteur charcot des
planchers
entendez que ma forme
c'est vous qui lui fait
au rang des folles faites la taire
vous pourrez tout dire
contaminé tout fondement
[Musique]
oh
nous sommes nous je ne reconnais pas le
non pas ce à quoi la salpêtrière dans la
salle de tri n'ont pas ça
je n'ai rien à faire ici
ça ce n'est pas toi qu'il dessine ton
pain c'était son père
maintenant c'est le docteur charles quoi
c'est comme ça
ne bougeait pas marié
déclenché
aux yeux se ferment vous entendez que ma
voix
est-il vrai que vous communiquer avec
les morts mademoiselle tout c'est quoi
calmez vous je me calme si je veux
à
nourrir
[Musique]
dans son
houssam forte
ça me va
ça nous était indépendant
l'oms et messieurs je vous prie
maintenant d'accueillir celle que vous
attendez tous
les dames c'est à vous